Speaker 1: One more thing I want to briefly touch
on related to the of all the school shooting. We
now are very familiar in the United States with
this circle where nothing happens. Okay? And I
know that I'm sounding negative and cynical, but
this is typically the way that it goes. And you
can start the circle anywhere. I'll start with
the mass shooting. Mass shooting happens. Okay.
Explosive media coverage for several
days a week. A couple of weeks.
Tragedy. Something must be done, but not too much.
Because people need their gun rights. And you got
to stop bad guys with guns, with good guys with
guns and. Okay, we don't want to do too much,
but something must be done. It's a tragedy. Okay,
well, since you can't really get anything done
because. Oh, we can't restrict we can't do that.
We end with thoughts and prayers and there's
vigils and all of these different things.
Okay. And then a little bit of time passes.
And the more guns in more places, people get
really defensive about doing anything to make
it harder to get guns and to reduce the supply
of guns floating around. So you get gridlock and
nobody ends up doing anything. And then people
forget about the last major shooting now in this
case. You know, when we say we're back to normal.
The last mass shooting was like the last major
nationally significant mass shooting because there
were a bunch of between was Buffalo 11 days ago so
back to normal now means it's been like a week
since the last major mass shooting. But we're,
quote, back to normal and nothing gets done. And
then there's another mass shooting and the cycle
starts all over again. Except it's just happening
more quickly because like I said, the last one
was 11 days ago. We weren't even really back
to normal. It's just now normal that there's
been a mass shooting a few days ago. That's
the cycle. And unless you break that cycle,
sadly, nothing's going to change. Let me know
your thoughts. Find me on Twitter at D Pacman.